we welcome you back to CBS mornings we
have an exclusive joint investigation
with Kaiser health news into an unproven
Dental device now some former patients
allege in lawsuits against its inventor
that it damaged their mouths and in some
of them say that they lost their teeth
yikes our consumer investigative
correspondent that's Anna Werner first
started looking into this last year Anna
good morning to you good morning Gail
yeah CBS News partnered with khn on a
nine-month investigation of what's been
called the anterior growth guidance
Appliance or AGA the inventor says this
device has been used on more than ten
thousand patients and claimed it could
cure serious health conditions sleep
apnea and the jaw joint disorder called
TMJ but our investigation found no
peer-reviewed studies to back his claims
what we did find patients who said the
device mangled their mouths a warning
some of the pictures you'll see may be
disturbing
[Music]
performed with Symphonies around the
world this was her in 2013.
I've spent my entire life studying the
instrument and trying to climb up the
ladder of being a musician and always
getting better at doing it but a
breathing difficulty interfered with her
playing my jaws are both too far back
and therefore it impinges on the airway
and makes the airway really quite small
once told her she needed double jaw
surgery to move both her upper and lower
jaw forward but then she heard about a
device on Facebook called an anterior
growth guidance Appliance or egg a
retainer-like appliance promoted as
something that could expand the upper
jaw without surgery it's predictable
it's stable and it's safe this is the
aga's inventor Tennessee dentist Dr
Steve golella seen here in Australia
training dentists to use his device in
2017. he claimed that AGA could cure
problems like TMJ and sleep apnea can
you cure TMJ yes can you cure mild to
moderate sleep apnea yes even make
patients look better good-looking people
get all the breaks they get the best
jobs they get the most money and he said
it would benefit the dentist too it's
okay to make a crapload of money
you're not ripping anybody off you're
curing them you're helping them you're
making their life totally beautiful
forever and ever krugula says she went
to a dentist who told her she'd attended
one of those training courses how did
she explain to you what the appliance
was going to do she said that the
appliance would grow the Jaws forward
she says she paid some fifteen thousand
dollars for the AGA treatment using a
device like this one that attaches to
front and back teeth soon she says she
noticed a gap between her canines those
upper pointy teeth and the teeth behind
them something she says her dentist told
her meant her Jawbone was growing
forward I thought it was sort of
miraculous and exciting but as the
months went by she says her front teeth
flared outward her dentist later put on
braces she said were part of the
treatment but krugulia says her teeth
were loose and painful so finally she
went to an orthodontist for a second
opinion he lifted my lip up and just
immediately said it was the worst thing
he'd ever seen and he was like
you weren't growing the jaw and you have
a really serious problem you know the
teeth are completely out of bone and the
bone is gone and I mean what's your
reaction at that point I was in shock
she says she can no longer perform on
clarinet in November of 2021 doctors had
to remove her Forefront teeth it's just
like sitting down and watching someone
cut your fingers off um
they're really gone you know and um
and to see yourself without teeth is a
bizarre experience
hers isn't the only story a joint CBS
News khn investigation has found at
least 20 people including gregorya who
have sued Dr gallella and others over
their AGA treatment all of them said he
consulted on their treatment plans with
their dentists we interviewed 11
patients all of whom told us they wound
up worse off than they started my front
six teeth also became extremely flared
outwards all six of them instead yes
they were doing this I noticed my teeth
were starting to get loose I can't bite
into absolutely anything I feel like all
I have to look forward to now is
treatment and pain and fear and debt Dr
George mandelaris is a board-certified
periodontist who saw Boya krugulia her
mouth is a catastrophe
it's like a bomb went off in her mouth
he says he's consulted with nearly a
dozen former AGA patients how would you
describe what they were subjected to
uh
uh abuse and he says they needed urgent
treatment because if you don't
they're going to lose their teeth
plain and simple plain and simple
Dr mandelara says he was so disturbed by
what he saw he went looking for any
studies that supported the use of the AG
device there was none
in the peer-reviewed literature
zero in an email Dr gallella's attorney
told us his client wouldn't sit for an
interview citing the pending lawsuits
but told us the device now called the
Osteo restoration Appliance when
properly used is safe and can achieve
beneficial results for the patient that
it has been used by well over ten
thousand patients and Dr gallella had
had no complaints prior to the lawsuits
yet in one of those lawsuits Dr gallella
admitted he was not aware of any
peer-reviewed studies or clinical trials
demonstrating the AGA was successful
when used on adults whose Jaws have
finished growing Dr gallella something
we wanted to ask Dr gallella about my
name is Anna Werner with CBS News I
wanted to talk with you about your AG
device treatment okay talk to you how
can you feel comfortable using the
device on patients when you have no
proof no studies that it works
Dr Galileo
last year a judge ordered Dr golala to
provide before and after scans from five
patients to prove his device works so
CBS News and khn took those scans and
asked eight experts from Dental
Specialties and schools Nationwide
including Harvard and Columbia to review
them most said that expanding an adult's
Jawbone without surgery is
physiologically impossible and all said
they saw no evidence that the ago works
the entire
concept of this device of this treatment
makes zero sense they didn't grow bone
in these patients what they ended up
doing was
um losing bone is certainly
not going to do what it claims is going
to do I've not seen one patient that has
it had anything good come from this
device nothing this is snake oil this is
this is crazy
kragugia now has false teeth she
estimates the cost to fix her jaw and
mouth now at a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars plus she says she's
been told by her doctors she may lose
more more teeth pardon me gallella's
attorneys in court argue that patients
were warned about potential
complications including teeth dying or
removal of teeth they also told us
krugulia's dentist installed her AGA
incorrectly and kept it on too long the
dentist's attorneys declined to comment
the device is still being marketed
around the country that's what I was
wondering can people still get this
device is it still being sold they call
it that the images were going to be
disturbing Anna we're all sitting at the
table gasping because you can't really
hide your teeth when they look that bad
right and for a lot of these patients
that's part of it you know it's more
than just something happened medically
yeah there's embarrassment and shame one
of the ladies we spoke to said that when
her boyfriend goes to kiss her that her
teeth are too sensitive
oh
I couldn't see why he didn't talk to you
so he has nothing to say he still stands
by this product Dr galillo in in court
he his attorneys are defending the the
product yes
wow right you're coming back that was
shocking we'll be back tomorrow so
tomorrow we're going to tell you where
are where's the regulation right so
tomorrow we're going to talk to you
about why the FDA apparently has never
looked at this device yeah
all right Anna where I was supposed to
say that part I'm sorry
sorry John I thought I was supposed to
ask you Anna but it says tomorrow the
CBS News engage in investigation we'll
show you how this device got out into
the market with no clinical trials and
no one in the FDA was apparently even
aware of it I can't let me just say this
I can't wait for part two